moi je suis le bon élève j'ai écouté
tout ce que le gouvernement m'a demandé
et j'ai appliqué c'est à dire que depuis
le mode de septembre je travaillais sur
le dossier j'ai essayé de faire des
économies d'énergie on m'a envoyé un
courrier fin novembre pour me dire que
ma facture d'électricité d'être
multipliée par 5 ou 1er janvier donc qui
est passé de combien alors moi j'ai fait
autrement j'ai signé un contrat que le
contrat matinock et le contrat spécial
pour les boulangers et on m'a fait une
proposition qui était valable 48 heures
donc on nous fait des contrats on a
l'impression vous avez 48 heures pour
répondre et nous laisse pas le choix
dans la date de souscription du contrat
c'est ça arrive maintenant et là la
proposition de de tarif que j'ai c'est
je faisais 8000 euros de consommation
avec le taf avec l'ancien tarif et là je
vais passer à presque 28000 avec le
matin
alors nous on a reçu les nouveaux tarifs
au mois de juin renouvellement du
contrat au mois de septembre c'était pas
le pire du moment on a fait les
prévisions on applaudf de 25000 euros
par an on allait passer à peu près à
80000 pour donc c'était compliqué du
coup dès le mois de juin on a commencé à
mettre des choses en place pour
économiser de l'énergie enfin tout ce
que on a fait le bon élève comme il dit
qu'on a essayé de faire au mieux
septembre enfin l'été ça va à peu près
septembre octobre-novembre moi je suis
saisonnier donc la terre saison
travaille très peu donc les factures ça
allait et là on a reçu la première pour
Novembre Décembre d'habitude on tournait
à 5000 par mois pour deux mois au nombre
de décembre et là cette année en faisant
25% d'économie d'énergie on est passé à
10000 à peu près donc x 2 alors en
faisant 25 % d'économie comment tu t'en
sors non bah après on tape dans la
trésorerie parce qu'on a des entreprises
qui sont l'un comme l'autre dans les
entreprises qui sont assez saines
mais déjà ce que tu dis c'est fou parce
que ce que tu as envie d'aller taper
dans la trésorerie pour payer ton de
toute façon on n'a pas le choix si on
veut continuer à vendre nos business on
est obligé on a des crédits sur la tête
si on paye pas la facture d'électricité
on commence à faire n'importe quoi et
moi ça me tombe dessus on a derrière on
a des problèmes plus graves donc on tape
dans la trésorerie on n'a pas le choix
c'est clair on a de la chance d'avoir la
trésorerie d'avance on paye jusqu'à nous
on est là moi
je peux tenir comme ça en tapant dans la
trésorerie pour payer EDF parce que je
parle pas des matières premières là bien
sûr je peux tenir un an mais avec les
matières premières il y a déjà fluo
répercuter sur les prix de vente au
magasin mais si on doit répercuter
encore EDF mais on termine à des prix
c'est mais héros moi sur la tête moi
aussi
mais c'est mais héros tous ces mecs qui
sont patrons là en ce moment qui est qui
accepte de donner 60000 euros de leur
trésorerie pour sauver les emplois des
Français parce qu'ils sauvent des
emplois des mecs ils sauvent des
salariés c'est-à-dire que moi en tant
que patron je me dis est-ce que moi
j'aurais les corones de mettre 60 000 €
tous les mois en plus pour sauver mes
salariés je sais même pas si je le ferai
sincèrement on le fait rien c'est des
gens
je connais depuis que je suis installé
ils font partie j'aime pas utiliser ce
mot ça fait un peu pompe mais ça fait
partie un peu de la famille pour moi
bien sûr que je respecte beaucoup
est-ce que tu as trahi toute ta vie pour
mettre de l'argent de côté pour avoir
une trésorerie juste comme ça parce que
on a décidé les politiques ont décidé de
faire des choix de merde et de payer
60000 euros tu les reverras plus les
60000 €. alors voilà après on arrive sur
le système on arrive sur le système DZ
il nous dit il y a des aides il y a des
choses qui sont mises en place il y en a
plusieurs des aides là où on doit avoir
listing de toute façon moi devient
beaucoup qu'on sait plus quoi faire il y
en a il y en a une on nous dit on va
vous bloquer le prix du kilowatt à 280
€, enfin on va 280 €. nous on se dit sur
le coup c'est top après on regarde un
peu 280 € en moyenne sur l'année on
regarde moi en ayant ma facture qui a
fait x 2 je suis à 170 de moyenne sur
l'année donc celui qui a 280 il fait x 4
le mec c'est ingérable c'est pas
possible après on lui dit il va y avoir
l'amortisseur qui va être directement
pris sur les factures que dalle pour
l'instant ils ont des effets d'annonce
ils balancent ça la télé sur vos
plateaux sur toutes les chaînes de télé
et derrière nous il y a rien on appelle
EDF j'ai le numéro de téléphone portable
du responsable commercial chez EDF c'est
ça parce que notre région Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes
280 €, il me dit c'est du flan il me dit
bah lance ça me dit non on est même pas
au courant de quel droit il balance
n'importe quoi n'importe quoi donc là on
a été reçu à l'Assemblée nationale nous
par quelques minutes par quelques
députés enfin des nups mais ils nous ont
dit clairement on va essayer de faire
quelque chose mais le gouvernement
aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'ils ne
veulent pas ils ne veulent pas pour eux
ils disent les gros vont rester et les
petits ont enfin pour rester un peu poli
mais c'est pas normal ça c'est pour
rester polis
[Applaudissements]
et donc je suis pas encore
qui a été mis alors c'est renseigné ça
c'est vrai ou pas
ça il y a eu un problème de du relevé
non ça c'est d'accord parce que
la personne on l'a contacté et qui en a
réussi à avoir son magasin parce que en
parallèle je suis dans une association
qui gère un peu qui essaie de rapatrier
des problèmes comme ça pour qu'on puisse
les remonter à l'État et du coup on a il
y a quelqu'un de chez nous qui a
directement pris contact avec cette
personne tu en as au magasin le mec
était au ski pépère ah d'accord bah très
bien à 18000 € d'électricité
mais bon c'est pas non ça c'est non
Nicolas toi tu m'as dit tes boulangers
depuis 25 ans
combien de temps tu peux tenir
je dirais jusqu'à la fin de l'année et
moi j'ai une question à vous poser si
vous dites on paye pas qu'est-ce qui va
se passer
alors c'est pas bien de dire ça je vous
pose la question
[Applaudissements]
ils ont pas coupé le courant mais ils
lui ont laissé un kilowatts donc
l'ampoule donc ça veut dire la baguette
pour la faire cuire
à la maison
les compteurs on a des compteurs jaunes
c'est l'équivalent des Linky il fait un
Steven dessus hein donc on est mort on
est on est cuit là-dessus quoi c'est
c'est c'est ouais il y a pas je crois
qu'il y a la branche énergie à Marseille
de la CGT qui a coupé volontairement ils
ont coupé pour aider justement à venir
couper chez moi s'il faut je donne
l'adresse il y a pas de souci non mais
c'est illégal franchement mais c'est
bien d'avoir mais ce qui nous font là
aujourd'hui enfin en temps de guerre on
prenait enfin c'est comme un crime de
fin c'est un crime contre sa nation
enfin je me demande il y a quand même
quelque chose qui est pas normal on nous
on met au pied du mur et on s'est limite
dans la tête aujourd'hui c'est un truc
de fou je te jure c'est pas normal et
puis leur système d'aide leur système
d'aide mais on ne s'en sort pas il y a
on quelqu'un dans notre association qui
a demandé à sa comptable pour lui
préparer les dossiers d'aide pour
récupérer 1700 euros la comptable
demande 1000 euros
en même temps qui travaille gratuitement
le comptablement un moment de faire des
efforts
la semaine prochaine il y aura je
voulais dire non mardi 31 on sera avec
le porte-parole du gouvernement Olivier
vert on pourra face à papa spéciale je
mettrai des boulangeries boulangeries
parce que il y a urgence il y a urgence
là c'est quoi l'urgence c'est l'urgence
bouclier tarifaire pour tout sur jaune
c'est ça pourquoi c'est pas possible il
y a plus de sous
il y a plus de sous non mais ce matin
c'est ce qu'on nous a dit à l'Assemblée
nationale on a des nous on a un collègue
on a un collectif il y en a trois qui
ont été reçus à Bercy à la fin de la
manifestation ils ont gardé 1h30 pendant
une heure et demie pour leur dire bah en
fait on fera rien là on vous garde dans
le bureau de fer bien ils ont dit mais
qui on va ressortir du coup il va se
passer quoi là on leur dit quoi dehors
ceux qui sont dehors
ils savent pas parler on se demande les
gens ils savent parler sur le plateau
télé faire les beaux annoncer des choses
et une fois qu'ils sont là ben ils
savent quand ils sont avec nous enfermés
qu'il y a pas de caméra ils veillent ils
peuvent aller dans des clips mais pas
nous si ils font les prendre dans les
fournis ici ils savent pas on va les
faire bosser gratos quoi c'est sûr alors
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous êtes
extrêmement sympathique tous les deux et
après mais je sais que vous en avez
vous dire gros sur la patate non non
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est
mais là il y a urgence et c'est
important je voulais je voulais vraiment
que vous veniez ce soir parce que
c'était la manifestation des boulangers
aujourd'hui et je vous le dis à ce
rythme là il y aura plus de boulanger
dans deux ans voilà c'est c'est il y en
a qui ferme tous les jours les mecs un
peu moins c'est non mais je te dis non
mais là je te parle dedans c'est
vraiment une affluant quoi tu peux aller
que dans la grande
distributions
c'est dommage parce que chaque boulanger
il y a 33000 boulangeries en France
chacun a son sa petite personnalité bien
sûr des trucs qu'on aime on n'aime pas
mais moi je suis dans un petit village
on est trois boulanger-pâtissier bah
chacun on a notre nos petits produits
nos choses chacun à nos clients on a des
clients qui font le tour de trois parce
qu'on a chacun des produits différents
faut penser à tout ça c'est la diversité
c'est là c'est en France c'est les gens
viennent en France en vacances on la
bouffe le parfum la mode bien sûr mais
si on enlève si on enlève une partie
on va essayer de faire beaucoup
d'ailleurs merci vraiment nos clients
parce que nos clients quand je croise
des clients dans la rue ils disent enfin
ils nous soutiennent on comprend ce qui
se passe bien sûr vous allez encore
augmenter mais ils disent pas on va
partir mais ils comprennent la situation
vraiment il comprenne ça en parle
tellement de partout ils comprennent